hello welcome to my linear algebra
series about matrices and matrix math
this is the first episode I'm gonna go
over some basic concepts and just some
things you'll need to know I'm gonna be
using this [ __ ] image editor as my
little chalkboard type area so that way
I can modify things as needed so to get
into the basic concepts I'm basically
we're just gonna teach you what a matrix
is today and let's see here we're gonna
create I guess I'll just do a new image
leave that old one there so the most
basics of a matrix is a matrix is a
rectangular array of elements arranged
in horizontal rows and vertical columns
so you'll see it often represented
something like this some large brackets
and then some elements within like maybe
we'll have a 2 a 3 4 we'll just put some
random things here 2 7 and 8 a 9 6 and a
4 and you'll often see it represented
with some sort of capital letter and it
equals so this would be a matrix a which
is size 3 by 3 and the columns are often
represented by the letter J and the rows
are often represented by the letter I so
this here being in the first element
would be a 1 1 so you'll see that as
let's see here what do I have space
amount of space so if you see something
like this a 1 1 well a 1 1 equals and
you're trying to find the answer you go
over here and you look for into the
matrix a in the area 1 1
just i 1j1 and it's - and there you go
so if you change this up a little bit
and you say I don't know what is a 3/4
well that doesn't exist because there is
no 4 so what is a 3 2 a 3 2 would be
while you go to the 3 on the row you
know it's go over the row first the rows
always first which would be here yes
this is first one second one third one
and then you want to go to the 2 on the
column so that would be 2 here so this
would be a 3 2 and the answer would be 8
so that's some basic notation there of
how to access them and usually it looks
something like this and you know it's a
matrix sometimes people look brackets
around it just syntax that but it's kind
of however you want to do it in that
case and a few more basic things to
mention that are important let's see
here the elements that have an equal I
and J like this one here the to be you
know 1 1 7 being at location 2 2 4 being
a location 3 3 are said to be diagonal
so let's see am I missing anything else
here oh yeah these elements within they
don't necessarily have to be numbers
they can be anything like this could
just be an x squared or it could be some
other formula or function as the element
a matrix itself itself is not a number
so you can't say an entire matrix is
equal to some specific number like you
can with a lot of other things
I think that covers all the very basics
and will go further in the next episode
thanks for watching
don't forget to Like comment and
subscribe and check the links below for
more ways to support this channel and
we'll see in the next episode peace out